when Fulton County district attorney
funny Willis indicted former U.S
president Donald Trump and his
co-defendants this week she included a
rare and Powerful charge the indictment
said their alleged efforts to overturn
the 2020 presidential election results
violated Rico the racketeer influenced
and corrupt organizations act this is
the 11th Rico indictment we followed the
same process
the law and bring charges the indictment
says the defendants conspired and
endeavored to conduct and participate in
a criminal Enterprise in Fulton County
Georgia and elsewhere Trump co-defendant
Rudy Giuliani made a name for himself as
a federal prosecutor going after mob
bosses in New York City in the 1980s now
it is Giuliani who faces a RICO charge
the RICO statute is a way of
incorporating a number of defendants and
a number of seemingly different crimes
into the same count of an indictment so
that you can prosecute the entire scheme
as opposed to individual defendants or
individual charges in separate
indictments Giuliani calls the charge in
a front to American democracy critics
call it Poetic Justice a law created to
Target gangsters is now being used to
prosecute a wide array of people who
allegedly commit crimes together from
teachers to politicians and perhaps the
most aggressive Rico prosecutor in the
nation is the One charging Giuliani and
Trump in Georgia The Fulton County
district attorney fonnie Willis Willis
has used Rico before in 2009 to
prosecute Atlanta's School managers who
systematically cheated to improve
students scores on standardized tests
now she's taking on Trump and 18 alleged
co-conspirators these 19 people didn't
have to sit down in a conference room
and all decide hey let's overthrow the
government you know allegedly but but
anyhow they don't have to all agree to
the same conspiracy you can have tacit
agreements and what that means is that
you're moving with the conspiracy
without actually having a formal
agreement the racketeering charge is a
centerpiece of Willis Case the 160 acts
in the alleged conspiracy take up 58
pages of the 98 page and
now a jury will decide whether Trump
conspired like a mob boss to overturn
the 2020 election John hendren Al
Jazeera Atlanta
foreign